veamos cuáles son las derivadas de
algunas de las funciones más comunes en
este vídeo no vamos a demostrar que
estas derivadas efectivamente son las
derivadas de estas funciones pero por lo
menos vamos a conocer de todas estas
funciones súper comunes
cuáles son las derivadas empecemos con
las funciones trigonométricas veamos
cuál es la derivada con respecto de x de
seno b x la derivada con respecto de x
de seno de x es co seno de x
y bueno aquí no hemos demostrado nada
pero es muy importante saber cuál es la
derivada del seno de x
ahora con la derivada con respecto de x
de coseno de x pues ahora la derivada
con respecto de x de coseno de x
- seno de x ok eso también es muy
importante saberlo ok entonces la
derivada de seno de x escocia 9 x y la
derivada de coseno dx es menos seno de x
y ahora vamos con la derivada con
respecto de x de la tangente de x lo
cual es igual a 1 / coseno cuadrado de x
lo cual es igual a secante cuadrada de x
ok donde el cuadrado en realidad pues lo
pudimos haber puesto así
pero para hacer que la mención más
sencilla lo vamos a dejar así ahora
vamos a pasar a las derivadas de la x y
del logaritmo natural de x cae entonces
es la derivada con respecto de x de ea
la x y esto es algo súper padre es una
de las cosas más elegantes en
matemáticas y bueno de hecho esta es la
razón por la que el número es tan
importante entonces saber cuál es la
derivada con respecto de x de la x a
veces la x y bueno aquí vamos a tener
que hacer una gran pausa bueno no tan
grande pero una pausa porque es algo muy
padre y hay que verlo a fondo
aquí tenemos el eje de las equis y vamos
a graficar a la equis ok y bueno cuando
x toma valores negativos muy grandes o
sea valores por acá esto va a ser muy
chiquito ok se acerca muchísimo al cero
después cuando x toma el valor de cero a
la equis como el valor de uno como
cualquier número elevado a la cero que
entonces esto va a pasar por aquí y
después conforme x se hace grande
esto va creciendo y crece cada vez más y
más y más hacia el infinito
por eso asociamos la expresión de que
las cosas que sean exponencialmente como
que algo crece muchísimo bueno ya ahora
veamos qué es lo que nos dice esto de
que la derivada de a la x sea ya la x
eso lo que nos dice es que por ejemplo
si nos paramos aquí
y dibujamos la recta tangente que
pendiente tiene esta recta a ver ustedes
díganme qué pendiente tiene esta recta
pues justo para ver la pendiente de esta
recta tomamos la derivada de a la equis
que en este caso sea la equis y la
evaluamos justo en el puntito x osea la
pendiente de esta recta va a ser justo
el valor de la equis en este punto o sea
la pendiente de esta recta es 1 y bueno
qué tal que nos paramos en el 1 y nos
fijamos en cuál es la pendiente de la
recta tangente a ver si nos vamos aquí
en 1 entonces la función de la equis
aquí toma el valor de e
a la 1 que es también nada más el número
eno y resulta que la pendiente de esta
recta tangente a la gráfica de a la x
también vale en este punto y bueno o sea
si no vamos a cualquier punto y trazamos
la recta tangente a la equis vamos a
obtener que la pendiente de esa recta
vale justo lo mismo que a la x en este
punto pero bueno ese no es el punto de
este vídeo el punto este vídeo es hacer
un catálogo de todas las derivadas que
tú puedes necesitar
bueno ahora vamos a ver otra derivada
muy útil ahora vemos que la derivada con
respecto de x de logaritmo natural de x
eso es igual no me lo van a creer pero
es igual a 1 / x que también se puede
escribir como x a la potencia menos 1
les recuerda algo
de alguna forma el logaritmo natural de
x llena el vacío que dejó la regla de
los exponentes o bueno que también se
llama la regla de las potencias con esa
regla podríamos obtener derivadas del
tipo 1 entre x cuadrada o 1 / x a la n
para cualquier n mayor o igual a 2 pero
la regla de los exponentes no está en
ninguna forma de obtener uno entre x
como una derivada y el logaritmo natural
de x llena ese vacío ahora no lo estoy
probando aquí lo vamos a probar en los
próximos vídeos pero aquí hicimos un muy
buen catálogo de algunas funciones con
sus derivadas y vamos a usarlas en los
próximos vídeos y demostrar estas